[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the google pixel slate this tablet uh
it was announced alongside the pixel 3
back in october i ordered one then it
didn't ship for a couple weeks it was a
little bit delayed but now i've got mine
and this thing has made me
so sad
and confused
and curious but mostly sad like if i was
doing a tablet awards show also for 2018
this one would most likely end up
getting the toilet bowl trophy bust of
the year
here's why so whenever a new tech
product comes out and it's a letdown
obviously that's a disappointment for
everyone but it's an even bigger
disappointment when the expectations and
the potential were sky high so that's
like something what happened with the
phone bust of the year the red hydrogen
i'm someone who likes a lot of red
products i respect what they do they
announced they're coming out with a new
product that's a phone my expectations
are way up here the phone comes out it's
really bad then that delta between what
i expected and what we got was just
drastic that's what's happening again
here with the pixel slate so when the
ipad pro came out earlier this year i
thought like wow this is going to be
really hard for anything to beat this
the ipad already had this huge lead over
every other tablet and they just took
another huge step forward with this
build and this incredible performance
like how can anything else measure up
there are other tablets of course that
do other things well but none of them
really touched the ipad as far as
usability but then pixel slate just kind
of loomed on the horizon so when i
finally got mine i was really pumped and
i want to give it a shot at possibly
taking over all of my tablet use like
maybe this will be just as fun to use as
the ipad pro maybe even more fun because
it has a few key advantages like right
off the bat any first impression of a
device starts out the box with the
aesthetics and this is a solid looking
tablet it's almost matte black it's this
sort of dark matte blue all the way
around there's almost no logos but just
a subtle classic g in the corner and
it's a pretty symmetrical and balanced
no camera bump at all that's a good
start and the more i looked into this
the more i remember all these reasons
that google was telling me back in
october why this was going to be the
dopest laptop tablet convertible
and to me i don't know possibly better
than the ipad pro so it has a pair of
stereo front-facing speakers just like
back in the nexus 10 days so audio is
actually facing towards me and i can
pretty much never accidentally block
them and the sound turns out is pretty
good it's got volume it's full
it's great for a tablet and then the
display is by far the flagship piece of
this hardware it's not 120 hertz but
everything else about it is super high
end it's a 3 000 by 2000 12.3 inch
display so a little taller than 16x9 and
plenty sharp it's called a molecular
display i don't know why they have to
name everything but they do the point is
it's super crisp this is the max
brightness it's not very bright but it's
still indoors plenty fine and really
good looking for watching shows and
videos and things like that and then
there are even smaller things like the i
o there are two usbc ports one on each
side uh either one can be used to plug
in to charge and you can plug in both at
the same time if you want to one for
charging and one for some accessory and
even the power button on the side
doubles as a fingerprint reader so no
need for face unlock but basically every
time you hit the button you're already
securely unlocked and then it has these
smart pins at the bottom that work
perfectly with this incredible pixel
slate accessory that i think is
objectively better than apple's the
keyboard so the slate sort of slaps into
this keyboard at the connector and then
there are enough magnets in both the
tablet and the folio the case itself
that you can connect it to prop up the
back and once they're connected it's
literally any angle instead of just some
set number of fixed angles and on top of
that it has chrome os which on paper is
a nice combo of chrome for all your web
stuff plus the play store for all these
android apps all in one place and the
usb c ports that can actually read
accessories like sd cards and storage
drives it's a proper power users
paradise so i was pumped about all of
this like my expectations are really
high there's a lot of great hardware
maybe this will unhook me from the ipad
pro and be just as good
then i used it
and pretty much all of that went
directly out the window welcome to
lag city population pixel slate
you might remember i
i didn't show my first impressions of
the pixel slate in my video where i went
to google before they unveiled the pixel
3. and that was because i literally
thought there's no way it's this bad and
it's pre-production software and i'll
give them the benefit of the doubt and i
didn't show it on camera and i just did
a pixel 3 first impressions but i did
see this in pre-production mode but now
that they're shipping it like this
uh it's
this is it it's almost unbelievable this
is
real time the animation for multitasking
legitimately takes several seconds and
it's everywhere scrolling is not fast
loading pretty much anything is slow i
feel like this whole ui runs at like 12
to maybe 20 frames per second usually
pinch to zoom in pretty much anything
but especially in web browsing is
usually lag city it's just not fun and
like no matter how many features you
throw in here no matter how powerful
chrome os can be i'll never be able to
use this tablet long enough to even
discover half of that stuff because it's
just really not fun i've been trying to
force myself to use this tablet for the
past couple days on and off messing with
apps flipping back and forth between web
apps and native apps and doing some
writing and watching videos etc but i
never really got very far because within
minutes i'm just sitting there annoyed
at how much lag and choppiness there is
everywhere and of course that is a stark
contrast basically the opposite of what
makes the ipad pro so fun to use which
is the excessive effortless and smooth
performance thanks to that a12x bionic
it's massively powerful so i'm thinking
a lot of that has to do with the spec i
bought this is the baseline model so 600
bucks so it is cheaper than the ipad pro
and for that money you get four gigs of
ram
32 gigs of internal storage and an
internal intel celeron processor
which you know that's probably a
bottleneck so if i give them that
benefit of the doubt i'd have to spend
about 800 bucks which is the same as
ipad pro money just to get out of
celeron world or maybe i should have
gone with the i5
but for chrome os
i like
really they shouldn't either way they
shouldn't ship this one this is so sad
honestly and i had a lot of hope but i
literally haven't been able to force
myself to use it long enough to dive
into the more niche features or really
test the battery life or any of that
because none of that stuff even matters
if at the surface it's borderline
unusable the good news if you want any
is this is all software and in theory it
can all be fixed in the blink of an eye
with a software update and i've seen
good products get better but not a lot
of terrible things get to be great so
the chances of this tablet becoming
incredible are pretty low but let me
just say this isn't a completely useless
tablet it does have some upsides that i
survived long enough to notice chrome os
for example lets you connect straight to
your android phone so when i'm connected
to my pixel it can tether automatically
and use my phone's data when there's no
wi-fi
and it has a messages app so they sync
up and i can get texts on the tablet and
reply without picking up my phone it's
basically just like apple's suite the ai
at the top trying to predict what you'll
do next or what app you'll open next is
actually pretty good unlike some others
and with chrome since it's straight up a
web browser you can go split screen with
multiple tabs in multiple windows
it's still extremely slow and annoying
but if you know that the features are
here you can take advantage of this and
honestly this thing does much better as
a laptop than it does as a freestanding
tablet that now that requires buying the
optional 200 keyboard accessory
which is not cheap but it is really good
this thing first of all is made of much
more premium materials i've hated the
fingerprinty rubber apple uses for a
while this one's soft touch it's fabric
on the outside and the magnet is
stronger and once you connect it the
magnets stay stuck to the metal so you
have your infinite angles for adjustment
instead of just two or three literally
just by sliding it up and down
it has more specialized function keys
that work specifically in chrome os so
brightness media multitasking there's a
google assistant button and the keys
themselves have way more travel so
they're better for people who like to
type for a little while the keys are
freaking backlit so you can see them in
the dark and there's a trackpad and
mouse so it's basically a whole laptop
action happening there's two fingers
scrolling the whole deal obviously
something i really missed on the ipad i
could even go so far as to say the pixel
slate with this really good keyboard
accessory is closer to replacing an
actual everyday laptop than the ipad pro
is with its keyboard accessory
that would be a bold thing to say
but i could say it but without this
keyboard if you were planning on using
this as your daily tablet
this ain't it chief this is not the move
do not spend 600 on this my advice would
be
give a shot for the the i5 or i7
versions of it maybe performance will be
better and you can use it more often as
a laptop or if you only have that 600
bucks to spend
just get an ipad
so that's pretty much it a sad story but
that's the truth thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace